hello it's seven o'clock you're watching
Sky News breakfast these are our top
stories here this morning
one person is feared missing and
hundreds more are urged to leave their
homes as flood waters cause chaos in
eastern Scotland
how are you feeling
A month's rain has fallen in the area in
the past few days leaving homes
underwater
a form of war crimes investigator has
been appointed to oversee the criminal
investigations into the former U.S
president Donald Trump including his
alleged role in last year's Capital
riots
as Sky News hosts a major Science and
Tech event can the UK really have big
ideas and become the next Silicon Valley
as Jeremy Hunt hopes I think one of my
biggest fears over the next few years is
that we're going to have to move the
business quite rapidly off the shores of
the UK
packing their bags thousands of whales
football fans are setting off for Qatar
the head of their first World Cup for 64
years
a mother who became severely ill after
Contracting covid-19 whilst 36 weeks
pregnant has finally returned home to
her baby daughter after more than a year
in hospital
it's four to England etch out France to
win the wheelchair Rugby League World
Cup
in the weather there'll be some rain for
Eastern Britain Ireland and later
Northern Ireland but most other places
do look fine it'll be rather cold though
with Coastal Gales in the Northeast
and coming up at a quarter two we'll go
through the papers with the broadcaster
and journalist afore Hagan the author
Joanna Williams
[Music]
hello very good morning to you and
welcome to Sky News breakfast
one person is feared missing and
hundreds of people have been urged to
leave their homes in eastern Scotland
because of the threat of flooding a
search has been halted for a woman
thought to have been swept away into the
river Dawn while trying to rescue a dog
the emergency follows a month's worth of
rain in just the past few days in
aberdeenshire and Angus
well this morning there are almost 40
flood warnings in the area and some
householders already counting the cost
here's our Scotland correspondent Connor
Gillis
oh this is ruined
pieces in the kitchen
wrecked once again by water this is the
third time Kim's home in Britain has
been devastated by floods and this is
your this is your life this is your
belongings yep yeah again
how are you feeling
devastate
this is a community on edge a day spent
watching the torrents worried this River
May burst its banks behind that was a
river and there's um about five foot of
river behind that wall so I I don't
understand too much longer so yeah it is
a dangerous situation and if that was to
go in any way anywhere
um I think that's what the whole lot
would probably get washed away
fear for Alice who's one of 300
residents scrambling to evacuate 52
years and I've never had to do it before
and how are you feeling about that I'm
just anxious
just I'm living on my own so if you do
get a bet on [ __ ] so I'm better with
family this northeast corner of Scotland
has once again borne the brunt of these
danger to life weather warnings there's
a sense of deja vu elsewhere across the
country there's been significant
disruption record rainfall has made the
roads treacherous made the railway lines
impassable and forced the closure of
schools and now an emergency Hall is
home to those who are now homeless in a
community feeling vulnerable once again
Conor Gillis Sky news briefing
a former war crimes prosecutor is going
to oversee investigations into the
former U.S president Donald Trump Jack
Smith has been appointed as a special
counsel to oversee the criminal
investigations into the former U.S
president including his alleged role in
last year's Capital Riot the attorney
general made the announcement in
Washington but it drew a furious
response from Mr Trump
based on recent developments including
the former president's announcement that
he is a candidate for president in the
next election
and the sitting president's stated
intention to be a candidate as well I
have concluded that it is in the public
interest to appoint a special counsel
this horrendous abuse of power is the
latest and a long series of witch hunts
we started a long time ago I thought the
investigation with the document hoax was
dying or dead or over
and the investigation into January 6 in
my very peaceful and patriotic speech
remember peaceful and patriotically
Elon Musk has made a Twitter poll asking
users to vote on whether Donald Trump
should have his account reinstated the
Twitter boss called the decision to ban
Mr Trump a mistake because it alienated
a large part of the country the former
U.S president was suspended from the
social media site by its previous owners
in 2021 following the attack on the U.S
Capitol
British sunaka said he wants to ensure
his daughters can walk around safely
after Zara Alina's Keller Jordan
McSweeney admitted murdering the law
graduate McSweeney had 28 convictions
for 69 offenses and was released from
prison only nine days before killing
Zara in June hours earlier police had
attempted to arrest him for breaching
the terms of his release
once done by Forbes is the world's
youngest female self-made billionaire
now sentenced to more than 11 years in
U.S federal prison Elizabeth Holmes
founder of theranos has been convicted
by Californian jury on three counts of
investor fraud and one count of
conspiracy
the foreign secretary James cleverley
will use a speech to accuse Iran of
spreading Bloodshed and destruction in
an address at an International Security
conference today in Bahrain he'll warned
that iranian-supplied weapons are
destabilizing peace it's believed
iranian-made drones are being used by
Russia to Target Ukrainian civilians
now most of the focus on the
government's Autumn statement has been
on the pain that it's going to deliver
for millions of taxpayers but there was
of course extra spending too Jeremy Hart
promised an additional 3.3 billion
pounds in funding for the NHS for each
of the next two years but analysis for
Sky News suggests around half of that
funding will be eaten up by the costs of
inflation about 1.7 billion pounds next
year another 0.9 billion will be needed
to pay for growing demand which leaves
less than 800 million pounds left for
Health Services
or beyond the Health Service the UK
Science and Technology sectors also
promised a big funding boost the
chancellor increased the government's
research and development budget to 20
billion pounds a year by 2024 to 2025.
Jeremy Hunt said he wanted to transform
Britain into the next Silicon Valley our
Science and Technology editor Tom Clarke
reports on the challenges to that aim
each of these discs is a wafer of
sapphire they're about to be coated with
the Wonder material graphene a layer of
carbon just a single atom thick
this process being pioneered at this UK
company has the potential to
revolutionize microelectronics imagine
computers with graphene chips 50 less
energy a thousand times faster so it
really is a transformational material
despite being well funded with an
expanding list of clients the head of
this company has a problem how to stay
here I think one of my biggest fears
over the next few years is that we're
going to have to move the business quite
rapidly off the shores of the UK and
that's because there is more support
there is more capability for us to grow
in other countries these are the world's
first graphene-based electronic chips
and proof the UK can take a breakthrough
from the laboratory and turn it into a
technology that won't just generate
growth and jobs for potentially change
the world yet companies like this also
illustrate how the UK is failing to
create an environment in which small
Science and Technology businesses go on
to be world leaders I want to to combine
our technology and science Brilliance
with our formidable Financial Services
to turn Britain into the world's next
Silicon Valley
the chancellor championed science in his
budget protecting research and
development funding from a much feared
cut the sector will be relieved but to
become Silicon Valley the UK has to take
its breakthroughs to the next level it's
not just about big brains aching with
knowledge it's not just about people
kind of coming up with discoveries it's
then about creating a kind of pipeline
where that knowledge and the technology
and the expertise can be made useful to
companies and to Public Services into
society
realizing that vision isn't just about
throwing money at science the UK doesn't
currently have a Silicon Valley
investment culture government-backed
Innovation hubs have yet to prove their
true worth
Technologies like graphene computer
chips are set to transform our lives but
whether they'll be made in Britain
remains a question Tom Clark Sky News
Cambridgeshire
well to hear more from our Sky News
Specialists and the biggest thinkers and
experts about how Science and Technology
will impact the way we live do come
along to our big Ideas live in East
London or you can tune in from Sky News
to Sky News rather from 10 a.m scan the
QR code on screen now or you can visit
our website skynews.com forward slash
Big Ideas live to get more information
now around 3 000 Wales football fans are
arriving in Qatar to support their home
nation as they prepare to play in their
first World Cup for 64 years Sky's Dan
Whitehead spent the day with two
families from South Wales as they
prepared to Jet off to the Middle East
how far do you think we'll get I reckon
the group yeah well that'd be good if we
do it's a journey dad Marcus has been
waiting his whole life to pack for this
weekend he and his son Theo will be
swapping Cardiff for Qatar and joining 3
000 other Welsh supporters heading to
the Middle East
I can't believe it really never going
out there he's amazing in it it's just
like I said for me as well I mean I've
been supporting Wales for 42 years so
you know I've seen all the
disappointments over the years the the
near misses and uh this is like probably
a once in a lifetime really and I think
every Wales fan is going is just going
to be on cloud nine when we get it
because obviously a lot of the other
bigger countries they used to qualifying
so I think it means a bit more for us
and there has already been plenty of
chatter among red wall members about
what to expect to be told that the
alcohol prices are really extortionate
so we're prepared for that
um but I think it's just the fact that
you know we just got to embrace it
really I think the fact that we qualify
we're trying to focus on the positives
and having a party while we're over
there as much as we can how excited is
it to see whales in the World Cup it's
gonna be really good actually
yeah the excitement is building further
down the M4 Hugh Hudson and his
daughters usually follow Wales on the
big screen at home also be heading east
it's so I've been dreaming of since I
was a child and die hard Wales fan
Swansea City fan that's all I've ever
wanted to do was see where I was at the
World Cup there's plenty of times where
I never thought it'd happen
um so to actually be going is just it's
a dream come true once in a lifetime
probably
[Applause]
[Music]
it has been a long wait this will be the
first whale side to play in the
tournament since 1958. the last time
this station was in a World Cup Harold
MacMillan was prime minister of
Duty years away however well whales do
in this competition one thing is for
sure they have inspired the Next
Generation
it is so exciting I almost had a tear in
my eye at one point to you yeah it was
so good I would love to be a footballer
I love to play very excited and why is
that well also because yeah they haven't
been in the World Cup for a very long
time and I find
hopefully they're gonna win yeah
Wales lost to Brazil in the
quarterfinals in 1958 on Monday they'll
play their first game against the USA
before facing Iran and England
whatever happens this time fans both at
home and abroad will be hoping to raise
a toast
to a Welsh Victory Dan Whitehead Sky
News in South Wales
now negotiators are trying to sort out
solutions for the future of global
warming at the cop 27 event in Egypt
which is continuing into this weekend
the tough talks there come as the UK
government this week extended the
windfall tax on oil and gas companies
operating in the North Sea the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt unveiled a
package of windfall tax increases to
raise 14 billion pounds for government
coffers so let's talk about all of that
now shall we are joining me from Egypt
is Safi gozari Monroe whose energy and
climate commentator and director at the
global wind energy Council so a very
good morning to you at sepi lovely to
talk to you this morning at so cop27
drawings were close at this weekend or
negotiations going on we assume it'll
end this weekend
um is it reassuring to hear in that
context Jeremy Hunt the chancellor in
the Autumn statement
recommitting the UK saying the UK
remains fully committed to the Glasgow
climate pact which was agreed at cop 26.
yes although I wouldn't expect anything
less really the UK is very proud of the
Glasgow climate pact and um is Keen to
maintain momentum there and in fact
progress it at this cop and I think you
know here we've we've seen quite a
struggle and you know at best we're
looking at reaffirming uh the Glasgow
climate pact with some movement on a
loss and damage fund and but at worst
we're looking here at a lack of
consensus because some quite thorny
issues uh are still undecided here you
know that the conference is already
um you know over a day uh late uh and
and uh people are expecting to be here
again overnight
well yes and we might explore a little
bit more about those sticking points in
a moment but just as far as the UK is
concerned was there much in the Autumn
statement for environmentalists to
celebrate would you say
I think we just need to remember why we
we are in the crisis that we're in first
to put the Autumn statement into context
you know gas prices uh four households
by April and next year we'll have almost
tripled
um household energy bills so people are
really struggling and one way to really
reduce uh household bills is Energy
Efficiency that really helps to bring uh
bills down permanently but unfortunately
the Autumn statement is still not
um meeting the Tory party Manifesto
commitment in terms of uh the deployment
of funds in order to get Energy
Efficiency really off the ground uh in
the UK we've seen a slump in Energy
Efficiency measures since 2012 since the
conservative LED government
um cuts the green crap
um and as a result households are paying
through the north for uh for Rising
Energy prices so unfortunately whilst
there's some not good noises on Energy
Efficiency in terms of delivery for
households I'm not sure it will make a
huge difference for those struggling
this winter and next winter
oh sorry go ahead go ahead second Point
really you know about this extension of
the windfall tax but you know it's been
extended for for oil and gas companies
but actually it's I've been extended to
uh renewable electricity generators but
the key difference is that oil and gas
companies are getting a tax break are
able to offset any tax that they have to
pay uh on on investments whereas
renewable energy uh generators are not
getting the same Grace So essentially uh
what this could become is uh whilst
optically it looks like oil and gas uh
companies will be paying a high windfall
tax actually by offsetting it against
investments in new oil and gas
developments which is not extended to
renewable energy uh companies and they
may actually end up paying less tax than
Renewables which which really is a
perverse outcome
well yeah and on the on the issue of
Energy Efficiency the government would
stress we've just announced six billion
pounds to that end um it's from 2025 but
they they want to try and improve
efficiency they would say and the other
announcement that they might point to is
uh the green light for the building of a
new nuclear plant size well C in Suffolk
s apart for this Parliament is not new
money and it also does not mean meet the
manifesto commitment that was made in
terms of uh spend for um Energy
Efficiency and like I said it's not
helping hustles the new money from 2025
a may not be when the conservatives are
in power anymore who knows but secondly
it's also not helping households who are
struggling this winter and on next
winter most likely so the problem is
there's so much time has been wasted in
the last 12 months when we've known gas
prices have been going through the roof
uh you know dithering delaying we could
have deployed uh you know a million
Energy Efficiency uh measures and for
the most vulnerable households this year
to protect them uh this coming winter
and that's not been done
and a quick word on cop27 and progress
there the the talk was carrying on into
the weekend it was supposed to end
yesterday wasn't it I mean to what
extent is that energy crisis which is
not just affecting this country it's
affecting many countries around the
world having an impact you think on
progress countries are having to provide
support for people that's putting a
strain on their finances as some are
going back to fossil fuels which they
had been starting to phase out to try to
to fill that energy gap do you think
that's causing problems there and
preventing real progress the key thing
I'd say here anna is actually that um
what we've seen from the International
Energy agency is that gas demand has
actually Fallen worldwide in the first
half of 2022
so whilst the fossil fuel Lobby whilst
gas lobbyists are are trying to portray
this as a return to gas there has been a
short-term uh you know rush to replace
Russian gas which is understandable but
the reality is is that countries from
Big emitters the US uh the EU China
India are accelerating their momentum
towards Google energy generation and I
will say that this year feels like the
very first year where uh the pieces have
really fallen into place for many
countries who recognize that Renewables
are a way out of the inflation crisis
the energy crisis National Security
crisis and a food crisis so I think um
whilst uh there has been a bit of a
short-term backsliding the acceleration
the momentum in the real world to go for
Renewables because it's the most
pragmatic uh affordable and secure uh
Way Forward is is
really interesting sepiko Zari Monroe
always interesting to get your take on
things thanks very much indeed for
joining us there from charmel Sheikh
thank you
now a weather phenomenon known as lake
effect snow has paralyzed parts of New
York State nearly two feet of snow fell
in parts of Western and Northern New
York along the Eastern end of Lake Erie
well New York Governor Kathy hochel has
declared a state of emergency for parts
of the state and warned the most intense
snowfall is yet to come
nothing quite like that here
weather-wise but let's give you a full
picture now
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
well flooding remains a concern with
more wet and windy weather on the way
but today it does look drier overall
much of Eastern Britain is gray and wet
with a Brisk wind at the coast bringing
Gales to the Northeast elsewhere though
it's largely dry and cold with some
Frost and fog in places and low cloud
and patchy rain is going to Edge further
Inland across England during the morning
while lingering over Eastern Scotland
and it's going to stay pretty windy at
the coast as well
very good morning you're watching Sky
News breakfast a reminder of our top
stories here this morning one person is
feared missing and hundreds are urge to
leave their homes as flooding Causes
Chaos in eastern Scotland a former war
crimes investigator is appointed to
oversee criminal investigations into
former U.S president Donald Trump
and thousands of Wales football fans are
setting off for Qatar ahead of their
first World Cup 64 years
[Music]
Ukrainian Deputy defense minister has
told Sky News he's not ruling out an end
to the war by next spring Vladimir have
rylov also said that the possibility of
his country retaking Crimea from Russia
has not been ruled out he was speaking
to Skies security and defense editor
Deborah Haynes did you think is it
realistic that you could even have
retaken Crimea by January
you know there is a phenomenon called
Black Swan
so unexpected event
coming to calculations nobody expected
it to come
so I think
Russia can face a Black Swan in in the
country inside in Russia
and it can contribute to the success of
us with Crimea
they are also a military option as well
with some kind of combination of forces
resources and something else we can step
in Crimea for example
by the end of December
possible possible
not excluded let it be so and can you
just explain a bit more what kind of
Black Swan event could happen in the
next two or three months in Russia
Putin disappeared
for example due to some reason
or physical or political for example
or somebody from his Circle
something happened
or maybe a combination of very
disillusioned Society in terms of their
losses when do you negotiate with with
Russia
negotiate with Russia only when they are
ready to leave our territories could it
be finished before the 24th of February
I think being realistic we issued as a
military as a military
to you
um
[Music]
to follow this scenario that
we will need some time to build up some
kind of reserves or something and also
that you Russia will continue to send
massive people there
and of course in this case the war will
take some time
but my feeling is that by the end of the
spring
this war will over
it will over
by the end of the spring yes
Ukraine Deputy defense minister there
well more on the war in Ukraine now and
the story of A running coach from
Cheltenham who's now racing into
villages in eastern Ukraine to rescue
rescue injured people Chris Parry flew
out to Poland intending to join
Ukraine's military but in march across
the border on a supply run to kharkiv
and has been there helping ever since
and Chris joins us now live from Ukraine
very good morning to you Chris Perry
thanks so much for talking to us tell us
a little bit about the work that you're
doing there you're there helping people
getting injured people out as I
understand it but explain exactly what
you're doing
so I'm working with a group of
volunteers who've been volunteering uh
since the annexation of Crimea in 2014
so very experienced some local
volunteers and um basically we get uh
requests to evacuate people from the
most newly liberated villages on the
East
um a few days beforehand from usually
from family who have fled to the West
um saying my mum and dad my grandma or
whoever is in this Village and we think
it's going to be retaken soon can you
please go and get them out they have had
no word from them because of course it's
been occupied by Russia so we go in and
basically as soon into the military in
the previous photos say yeah you're good
to go we then go into the village which
essentially is now the new front and we
just run around bang on doors trying to
find anyone because of course everyone's
hiding out in their basements and
eventually we'll find somebody who then
said oh yeah Bob's over there we then go
to his basement
um hopefully try and persuade him with a
video of this relative
um and then they'll come out with us to
uh kind of the local town where we put
them in the house hospital with our feds
they've got a warm bed you know shelter
finally for the first time since I think
the most recent Village they've taken by
the Russians on the 3rd of March so
they've been living in basements since
then
well yes and give us more on that
reaction that you get from those those
relatives when you first approach them
how are people feeling they must be very
frightened
yeah so um we're very fortunate that we
are working with uh ukrainians but
sometimes when we haven't got a
translator all over with us
um things a lot more difficult because
of course I don't speak language and I'm
just a foreign person saying come with
us come with us in English which we
don't speak so they're very uh skeptical
and quite afraid
um we've had people basically say sorry
we don't want to come with you because
they're terrified we're going to take
you into the woods and shoot them
because they think we could be Russian
because they have no idea what has been
happening in the outside world because
they've just been locked in this little
bubble of this village with no out
cyclons no ukrainians there to talk to
them or soldiers or anything so they've
just been sat in their basement for what
seven or eight months with no outside
information so suddenly when a band
appears saying get in the van we're
taking you to safety like would they
believe us normally probably not
yeah so that that is tough and tell us a
little bit more about where you take
them do you take them out of the country
or do you take them to hospitals still
within Ukraine
so uh our group kind of um specializes
in little runs to the the front so we
will basically drive like an hour from
here in Providence to the front line
Villages take them uh basically out to a
nearby town which is uh they've set up
um uh a hospice which is now converted
into sort of refugee Center for these
people who have had to leave all of
their belongings and we get to take we
take them there and then they have um
kind of nurses there who look after them
for a few weeks whilst they kind of like
sort their lives out
and as I understand it
your job as a running coach in
Cheltenham so how are you finding it
there in Ukraine you talk about going to
the front line the new front line that
must be extremely dangerous how how are
you handling it
um
I don't know I think uh maybe I'm a bit
of an odd one but I kind of take each
day as it comes
um sometimes when you see some pretty
terrible things it does stay with you uh
for example seeing kind of uh
the burnt out corpse of uh her mother
who we were evacuating
um it was supposed to be evacuating her
and her daughter but unfortunately the
day before we arrived their houses was
hit so she the daughter very sadly burnt
to death and the mother was she was just
uh she was like a ghost
um so that that does stick with you but
in the moment you know you've got a job
um you've got a you're in a position of
care as soon as you pick these people up
you've got to just get out um and get
away from sort of the artillery or the
drones which is kind of constantly going
off around us so
um because of the intensity in the
moment it's fine but it's kind of when
you get back and you start to like think
oh that was kind of close that was only
100 meters away from us and that's when
you kind of think okay maybe uh maybe
you might like might run out but it's
worth it to save these people I think
and in the meantime you're trying to
raise money aren't you for for a new
vehicle tell us a bit about that and why
you need it
yeah so um in the summer it was kind of
fine going around in the van because the
roads I mean the roads don't they're not
roads they're just like tractor Trails
but it's okay because it's hard whereas
now I mean you might be able to hear
it's torrential rain and all the tanks
going up and down on these um on these
tractor Trails it's just a quagmire so
um I've been getting stuck quite
recently and with the winter coming with
snow and the ice this van just won't be
able to get to the places anymore
um and as the Russians are pushed back
in this area uh the roads are only going
to deteriorate so we're trying to
fundraise uh fourway four by four so
that we can actually keep the work
through the winter because for these
people the winter is the hardest time
because it's hitting like minus 50 minus
20. um even at the moment it's starting
to go below zero and just us trying to
find these houses we're getting pretty
chilly let alone being sat in a basement
for months and months
okay and you've got to go find me a page
for that haven't you um well Chris Parry
thanks so much for talking to us this
morning good luck with your work and um
stay safe thank you thank you very much
now the North Korean leader Kim Jong-un
has revealed his daughter to the world
for the first time as they inspected a
ballistic missile ahead of its launch Mr
Kim's daughter whose existence had never
been publicly confirmed before was seen
holding hands with her father expert
believe Mr Kim's daughter is ju I who is
estimated to be aged between 12 and 13.
now hundreds of hot air balloons have
filled the sky over the Mexican city of
Lyon today
I wish I was actually standing there
with that blue sky behind me um
participants from 20 different countries
have gathered for the annual
international balloon festival which
will take place over the next four days
and authorities in Mexico are expecting
at least 400 000 visitors to attend this
year
well from the blue skies there to the
weather here now
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon is sponsored by Qatar Airways
or flooding remains a concern with more
wet and windy weather on the way but
today it does look drier overall much of
Eastern Britain is gray and wet with a
Brisk wind at the coast bringing Gales
to the Northeast elsewhere it's largely
dry and cold with frost and fog in
places low cloud and patchy rain will
Edge further Inland across Eastern
England during the morning while
lingering over Eastern Scotland and it's
going to stay windy at the coast too
elsewhere it's going to be largely dry
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
still to come after the break we've got
the papers for you we're going to be
looking at what's making the stories in
the papers with the broadcaster and
journalist afore Hagan and the author
Joanna Williams is coming up next
[Music]
so time now to revisit the Saturday
morning papers here with me to review
them this morning are the broadcast and
journalist afore Hagan and the author
Joanna Williams so welcome back to both
of you we dealt with a certain number of
the front pages in the last hour but
there's so many different stories around
on them that there's still some left for
us to to take a look at aren't there and
Joanna you've picked out the Daily Mail
to kick us off kick us off you'll see
what I did there it's a World Cup story
and this is talking about the backlash
over the beer band that's just been
announced just two days before the World
Cup kicks off Joanna how's the Daily
Mail handling this
well with sadness let's say I mean I
think it's understandable for many
football fans having a pint of beer
whilst you watch the matches an integral
part of the experience and it adds to
the pleasure and it helps you get in the
mood get excited and cheer on your
football team and I think the fact that
this has been banned and banned at such
short notice is just yet another
illustration of of some of the
complications that are arising from
hosting the World Cup in Qatar I mean I
have to say some of them as if you was
going to come on to talk about I'm sure
are an awful lot more serious than a ban
on beer
um but but still this has come as a
shock to sponsors a shock to fans and
you know I I I I'm just sure there must
be a lot of people who organize the
World Cup who are thinking never again
well I hope they're thinking never again
because I think this is has really been
a very a difficult experience and and
the danger is it removes the atmosphere
um you know it's not respectful to the
people who have struggled in putting
together that you know people who've
actually lost their lives struggling to
put together this world cup building the
stadiums you know the whole thing just
seems to have been an unmitigated
disaster it seems to me well yes and one
of the sponsors Budweiser we saw on the
tweet on the screen just there tweeted
briefly I have to say well this is
awkward and then it did get deleted but
um
they
um obviously not totally happy about
that and some questions about what else
could change at the last minute as well
but um as Joanna was saying there in in
the context of some of the human rights
um allegations against a Qatar the
question of a beer ban obviously doesn't
seem so important and um on the front of
the Guardian they focus on on some of
the some of the other issues Around the
World Cup and this is about workers and
how they're paid
and there's so many issues surrounding
this uh upcoming World Cup starts in
what 48 hours and like you so rightly
said on the front of the Guardian is
saying the guards at the World Cup are
paid at 35 feet an hour so this is
migrant workers who are employed uh
security guards and they're going to be
stationed at Alberta Park and that's
just a day to do the FIFA fan space and
they will be there for uh up to 12 hours
a day when all the fans have gone home
they still remain there uh to guard the
area to make sure that it's safe and
secure and they are paid
35p an hour they get one day of the week
they don't really seem to know a lot of
Qatar all they know is their jobs
apparently they go to their job and back
to the accommodation and back again and
this is
um another example of the way that
migrant workers who are brought in into
Qatar to build these stadiums and it's
been said that six and a half thousand
people died making those stadiums and
now you've got stories of the pretty
appalling conditions and appalling pay
that migrant markets are going to be
under to make sure that this world cup
goes smoothly and like Joanna said it
seems to be pretty much an omni shambles
and we know that of course the fact that
people wanted to Stage this world cup
and Qatar has been so controversial from
the dump you know the allegations of
corruption that led to it being held in
Qatar in the first place and they are
just allegations but like Joanna said no
completely agree it does seem like this
world cup is completely a shambles it's
been quite a muted build up and what's
supposed to be a huge Festival of sport
has really been mired
um by the stories of the treatment of
Migrant markers by the deaths of them
and of course we can't forget
um the treatment of the lgbtq plus
Community which they're going to have
many concerns as we go into the World
Cup in the next few weeks it does seem
to have really spoiled like what I said
is supposed to be a people of sport yeah
certainly certainly proved a pretty
controversial hasn't it um let's move on
shall we and focus on a story inside the
mail Joanna that you want to talk about
and this is the fact that um civil
servants the PCS Union representing
civil servants is saying that um they
are threatening strike action and for
quite a long period of time it'll affect
a key government departments and there
is the prospect of of people feeling
feeling the effects of this
yes absolutely I mean this is civil
servants who are responsible for
passports uh driving licenses and uh
passport controls at airports
threatening to go on strike for up to a
month um in the run-up to Christmas and
I have to say normally I'm very very
sympathetic to people who want to go on
strike I'm fully supportive of the
Railway workers for example who are on
strike at the moment and absolutely
think people have the right to
um get together collectively and make
the case for an increase in their wages
particularly right now when we're seeing
such high levels of inflation but my
concern is really how many people are
going to feel sympathetic towards civil
servants when we've got such terrible
backlogs in the system people are still
struggling to be able to get a driving
test to have their driving license
renewed there are long delays in
passport applications and lots of this
does seem to be down to many people
still working from home backlogs that
are built up in the system
um over the course of the covid
lockdowns that have still not been dealt
with and I think you can be very
sympathetic towards people wanting
higher wages
um I'm even sympathetic towards paying
higher taxes
um but I think there is an expectation
that you have a decent level of Public
Service in return from that and I think
where people are suddenly where I begin
to
um lose sympathy if you like is when
you're paying higher taxes uh when
people want higher wages but you're
actually getting a worse level of Public
Service
um than you had two or three years ago
but John is there proof that there's
less there's lower productivity with
people working from home in these jobs
do we have actual figures on that
well we can certainly see lengthy delays
still in people applying for driving
licenses and passports if you have a
look at how long um if you go back to
2018 2019
um I'm not exactly sure for statistics
but I think it would be around six weeks
that you would wait for either a
passport or a driving license uh now
you're talking double or even three
times
um that that length of time obviously I
can't sit here and and directly relate
that to people working from home but
clearly something has caused that delay
and those delays have real consequences
on people's lives if you're wanting to
take a job working abroad if you're
wanting to you know terrible situations
of attending a relative's funeral abroad
and you are faced with a three-month
four months sometimes even longer than
that delay in getting a passport then
then that can have a really devastating
impact on your life yeah interesting to
know it's what is behind that whether
it's Staffing levels or as you say
changing and working practices be
interesting to find out wouldn't it um
we will move on to the mirror next and
this is the decision by Rishi sunak to
stop that sort of daily uh interview
being done by a cabinet minister or
certainly a minister on on that round
that they do on Breakfast Television
like like this show
oh yes absolutely we're quite used to
seeing government ministers popping up
across Breakfast Television every
morning to discuss whatever the issues
of the day are but Rishi sunak has said
that he wants to limit that to three
times a week and we have seen some quite
disastrous outings uh by ministers as
well on television and and some of them
haven't done very well at all and I
think what Rishi sunak wants to limit is
stories he wants to limit those
disastrous interviews he wants to limit
those awkward questions or perhaps he
wants to see or esteem that he's pushing
his government ministers get to get on
with their dumps and get on with the
dogs of the day and I think throughout
the period of the pandemic especially it
was essential to see um our government
ministers on television uh talking to us
about what was happening we've just had
the budget you know we're used to
ministers talking about what the
economic ramifications are going to be
for us and we need that daily but that's
not going to happen anymore no yeah
that's absolutely right and we're out of
time but we are going to talk about
Paddington in the next hour so join us
next time around thanks both for the
moment very much indeed
[Music]